breaking news today on a double Royal
Health crisis Buckingham Palace
announcing that King Charles our new
monarch will undergo surgery from an
enlarged prostate next week postponing
all his public engagements while
Katherine the Princess of Wales has
already undergone abdominal surgery
yesterday the princess hasn't been seen
in public since Christmas she'll now
remain in hospital for up to two weeks
we're told and has cancelled all public
duties until at least Easter in April
well Jord I discuss all this is talk
to's role at his Sarah Houston who's in
London and in studio with me here in New
York is Fox News contributor Dr Mark
seagull welcome to both of you Sarah
Sarah let's get to the the Royal story
aspect of this I can't remember the last
time there were two announcements like
this backto back um both supposedly for
Planned procedures but it all seemed a
bit rushed out to me what's your take on
this yeah and I suppose it depends what
they mean by planned uh doesn't it
appears we're told that the Princess of
Wales wasn't rushed into hospital this
isn't something that occurred over the
course of the weekend and has then led
to her being hospitalized this week but
we don't know for how long it has been
planned in the king's case he started to
uh feel symptoms he then saw a doctor
earlier on this week and he received his
diagnosis today and that led to the
announcement from Buckingham Palace that
he was going to undergo a procedure next
week now it's not ideal is it for them
have to make two major announcements
about uh the most senior member of the
royal family and the second most senior
female uh member of the royal family
within an hour and a half of each other
now baky and Palace stressing that what
the king is to undergo next week is very
much routine it is something that many
many men of his age will undergo and he
will uh undergo it for a short period of
time he'll have a short period of
recuperation where engagements will be
canceled but because of his symptoms
he's actually had to cancel engagements
that were due to PL take place tomorrow
and Friday a much more serious uh case
for the Princess of Wales because while
this was planned surgery and we're told
it was successful a 10 to 14 day stay in
hospital followed by two to three months
of recuperation tells us that this was
major surgery uh for the Princess of
Wales and we've got the Prince of Wales
William her husband ALS now canceling
engagements and taking time off work to
be at his wife's side and also looking
after their three young children so uh
significant impact on the royal family
and their ability to go about their
duties yeah absolutely um just T to to
Dr Mark eagel from a medical perspective
Charles is obviously a more
straightforward situation he's a man in
his 70s he's got an enlarged prostate
that's not an uncommon condition for men
of that age but the procedure itself he
is the monarch um will he be put under
for this and what will happen absolutely
and by the way Sarah said it it might
have happened precipitously what usually
happens is these symptoms acrew over
many months or years over the age of 70
80% of men have enlarged prostates they
don't all need procedures but when the
medications fail and it's not stopping
it so that you get an Easy Flow you have
a procedure and it's all about urine
flow within a large prostate exactly and
if if it doesn't you if you if you if it
suspended the flow or it interferes with
the you may have a procedure usually
these days Piers we're using a green
laser which actually is is quite a a
small way to go about it it's not a big
open procedure it's it's through the
urethra but it as Sarah just said it can
work and be you're done with it in an
hour maybe you're home the next day to
your point though it is done on under
general anesthesia generally propofol
which everybody's heard about that's the
Michael Jackson drug we use that for
colonoscopies for any procedure but also
ketamine so ketamine propol plus
ketamine is the usual we're gonna have
King Charles in ketamine storm is that
the headline next I hope not but he he
will probably go why why ketamin what
does that well because it puts you under
more Pro propol is is just a milder
lighter anesthesia but again this is an
actual procedure I thought K was an
elephant tranquilizer initially
absolutely you you have that right back
in the 70s that's what they started for
you're literally evaporating part of the
prostate with this the the front part
that's pinching on the urethra you're
literally using the laser to evaporate
it if you don't have that procedure what
happens ultimately well after a while
the medications fail and you would have
to have an open procedure which again is
the old scalpel method where we're
through with that now this is this is a
miracle for step forward will it have
any side effects going forward after
he's had the procedure for a few days
after you might have some burning when
you urinate some hesitancy when you
urinate a little bit of pain but then it
gradually responds over a few days not
like what we're hearing for the princess
right so this looks altogether more
serious and the fact we're not being
told what it is suggests there's
something more serious going on for
someone of 42 and otherwise in very good
health to be in hospital for up to two
weeks and then have basically three
months off work what does that tell you
this might be I'm concerned about this
uh I I like the point that Sarah just
made that it was planned but what does
Planned mean I believe them when they
say it's not cancer so that's very very
good point could it be a benign tumor
could it be a hernia could it be a gynec
ological procedure could it be related
to she had three children in 5 years
which is a lot but she was out there
saying I used hypnotherapy for this so
now she's she's re relying on privacy
and that makes me concern but Pierce
almost every single abdominal surgery I
can think of that's not an emergency
it's done through a scope these days or
a robot and you're home in a day so I'm
concerned so what what what could it be
I think something might have gone wrong
I'm worried about a complication I'm
worried about an infection you know she
went in there maybe something happened
she wasn't anticipating and two to three
months of recovery implies that there's
been something major here so it may not
have been a planned major surgery but
how do we know an infection didn't Ur
how do we know a complication didn't
occur she's going to be fine I have a
strong feeling she'll be fine but the
longer term recovery concerns me that
something went wrong Sarah where does
this leave us if King Charles is
unconscious and William is you know
looking after his kids and I mean do we
start heading down the list of people if
there's some Duty that the Monarch has
to perform what actually happens here
we're kind of into Uncharted Territory a
bit well look there's a very set
procedure in place should a monarch be
incapacitated due to ill health for a
short period of time and and if the king
does have to undergo a general
anesthetic and is unconscious then the
councilors of state would be called upon
should they be needed now the list of
the councilors of state is the the
Monarch spouse so cila and the next four
in line to the thr
traditionally now that list throws up a
few problems as you've alluded to there
Pier because it's the Prince of Wales
who we know is looking after his wife
and children then it's Prince Harry
who's in California the next on the list
the DU he's going to be he won't be
interim King will he no he won the Duke
of York princess be here but in planning
for an occasion like this at the RO
family decided that might be pertinent
to add a couple more onto the list so we
now have uh the princess Ro who is also
a counselor of state and the Duke of
Edinburgh so should they be required
they could be called on but I think it's
highly likely that the king will only be
out of action for a very short period of
time and while he's not conducting
public duties he'll still be receiving
his red boxes he'll still be able to
make decisions uh as and when they're
required